[Music]
the State Department estimates the
coronavirus has left more than 50,000
Americans stranded in other countries
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
planes evacuated around 300 Americans
from Honduras and El Salvador this week
chartered commercial airline flights are
also being used and military flights
remain an option Kris Van Cleave spoke
to Americans on two continents waiting
to hear when they can come home this
beaming face brought Michael and Whitney
Sabol to India after two years they're
finally adopting grace 22 days later the
corona virus is paralyzing the planet
and India is in a three week lockdown at
least 1,000 Americans are looking to
leave and the Seville's don't know when
they'll get home to their three young
boys in Georgia the State Department is
working on arranging repatriation
flights for more than 50 thousand
Americans abroad so far at least 9,000
have come home from 28 countries dozens
of flights in the coming days should
double that I didn't dream Alex curry is
one of about 4,000 American stuck in
Peru she arrived there a month ago for a
medical school rotation curry and opting
Sayyidi are set to be in residences at
California hospitals if they can get out
of Cuzco situation so this is really
nerve-wracking for us and curry has a
heart condition she's starting to run
low on medication that's also scary
because I am there's little they can do
but wait do you think - in India little
Grace has been passing the time by
learning her new brothers names Noah
for CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Washington I love little children's
voices Tony and I love watching them
learn in real time but as upsetting as
it is to be or imagine you're still
trying to get home I want to get home I
love little kids voice as well